so The Last of Us episode 5 trailer is
now out and after that big Cliffhanger
for the end of episode four I'm sure a
lot of you are asking questions about
what could happen next time well if you
can't wait then this is the video for
you and throughout it we're going to be
going over the new characters game
Easter eggs and all our thoughts on what
could be happening next time both
spoilers ahead as we will be talking
about who Henry and Sam are as well as
the locations that appear in the episode
and what goes down at them but out of
the way a huge thank you for clicking
this now let's get into The Last of Us
episode by trailer
things have gone great
haven't you heard Kansas City is free
[Music]
where is Henry
told me to forgive
where is the Justice in that
it ends the way it ends
[Music]
now we start off with Kathleen talking
about her group overthrowing fedra
Kathleen is a completely new creation
for the show but there are some ways
that we can put together what's
happening in the game all of the scenes
that we watched take place in four
happen during the Pittsburgh chapter and
we can kind of use that as a basis to
guess what's going on in Kansas in the
game you arrive to find the rebels at
overthrown Federer and this was because
they'd been starving people to the point
of desperation I think in this entry
that we might actually see that playing
out and get a flashback to the moment
that Federer were overthrown it seems
like Kathleen has a group of people sat
down and she's telling them a story
about what happened which is why she
says that things have gone great however
it looks like complete Carnage with
there being fires people getting bottles
smashed over their heads like it's a
like button and trucks run in the area
searching for Henry and Sam bottles are
used in the games as things that can
distract clickers and also things that
can be used as Weapons now we catch
Kathleen asking where Henry is and this
is a similar scene to the one with a
doctor in the last entry she's clearly
Out For Blood and my guess is that we'll
learn why she wants to kill him and his
brother so much in the game they had a
completely different backstory and the
pair traveled from Hartford to
Pittsburgh once the military abandoned
their qz where are you from all the way
from Hartford really
I heard some bad stuff going on down
there yeah the military
Place probably looks like this by now
yeah though they were in Kathleen's crew
already and they were some of the
collaborators that over their
people you see trucks roaming the street
shining flashlights and this is very
reminiscent of the Run truck from the
game that drove by the toy store as you
hit in it in the game Henry and Sam took
giul and Ellie to their Hideout which
was located in an office building
overlooking a gate to the bridge leaving
Pittsburgh they wait for Nightfall to
make them move and this was due to the
area only operating with a skeleton crew
at that point we see lots of stuff set
at night here and there could be a
similar thing going on now a big change
up from the game is that it looks like
Sam is death there was a clip released
in the weeks ahead trailer that showed
them speaking in sign language and here
it seems to further confirm that theory
Sam was in death in the game so
potentially this is me just grasping at
something that isn't there and they
could be talking in the sign language so
that they don't alert the trucks
clickers are of course a big threat in
this world and this and being able to
communicate without making a noise is
very important the subtitles on this bid
also look exactly like how they do in
the game which it is a nice bit of
attention to detail now next we get a
very important bit of text saying next
Friday that's right you Last of Us
is dropping on Friday because HBO don't
want to compete with the Super Bowl so
it's Sunday night Kevin spoilers fix so
no spoilers that's no more and instead
you're gonna be getting that Friday
feeling why why is Friday the happiest
day of the week because the next day is
a sadder day
off anyway it's possible that this Henry
and Sam stuff is a flashback as he
doesn't have the orange paint that we
see him wearing at the end of episode 4.
now it seems to be following the game
quite a lot as after breaking out the
city the characters made their way
through some sewers which we learned
were used to house a colony as you got
to the entrance you saw that it had been
painted a look like a magical castle
which is what we end up seeing here in
the game a character called ish had
washed ashore after spending months at
Sea trying to escape the infected he
made a little home in the sewers but
when he got hungry he ended up traveling
out into the suburbs beside it which is
when he came across a family ish started
trading things with them and over time
they built a relationship to the point
they were actually invited to come there
and live with him slowly a community was
built out from there that had lots of
families and one of the big things about
the last of us is our kids were pretty
much overlooked and either kill the cast
aside because they just slowed the
adults down this is one of the main
reasons why Henry left Hartford and
seeing a location like this is a massive
changer from what we typically get
unfortunately in fact it got in unless
the place was overthrown leading to
several people being killed ish managed
to make it out but I'm hoping we get an
infected scene down there like what we
do in the game episode 4 had the tears
of there being summing on the ground so
they might bail on that and then go from
there now in ticket with these moments
are shots of gyal and a figure walking
away and I'm guessing that this is Ellie
and yeah there's there's only two people
left for a reason upon making it to the
radio tower you had to pass through some
suburbs and during this time Rebels
arrived before the infected started to
swarm the location Sam was bit during
this and the next morning he turned
which led to his brother shooting him
Henry shot himself it looks like this
might happen in this episode we see Ali
and Sam on a bed passing notes to each
other and also Joe cocking a gun as he
sits up in a room this is a scope on the
end of it so I'm guessing this is the
sniper section that happens just after
you exit the sewers you come across a
big street and then down at the end of
it there's a sniper shooting at you
which you have to get to the houses in
the area are full of rebels but
eventually you clear the way and manage
to kill the sniper from this point you
take control of the gun and then the Run
truck shows up which you have to then
shoot looks like something similar is
happening here but instead of Raiders
it's of course Kathleen's forces we see
Ali running at one point and firing
backwards in the truck chasing has a
battering ram on it similar to the front
of the run one now speaking of having to
run Joe shouts run and we watch as the
infected come out like in the game they
seem to be walking out of a burning
house and it could be the one that we
see the explosion at earlier in the
teaser in the game when the Run truck
arrived a Raider popped out the top
throwing molotovs and when you shot him
he dropped it inside and this then
crashed which alerted the infected they
could do something similar here with it
being gel who shoots a truck and then
lets them free now we are finally
finally finally getting a blotter in the
show which they've held off from
dropping until now originally in Bell
section you came across one in the
school but this was changed up to give
us the Frank stuff in episode 3. These
are super infected people that have
likely had cordyceps since the outbreak
and over the last 20 years they've
changed in a giant Mushroom Men their
one-hit kills and completely brutal
basically tearing you apart with their
bare hands once they get them on you
it's a big thing for the show and it
looks like it's setting up a major
actions seen in this episode judging by
the people in the scene it also looks
like Kathleen and her crew are there so
we're gonna get a big moment between the
infected and humans anyway that wraps up
the trailer and I hope you've been
enjoying the video so far if you want to
know the Last of Us won then I'd
definitely recommend that you check out
filmwise's Brighton of Craig Mason's
career and how it plays into some of the
major themes in the show Philip is a
good friend of mine and he's just left
running new rock stars to start up his
own thing and I'm not even gassing it's
one of the best put together videos that
I've ever seen editing is Top Notch and
he's picked up on so many things I've
not seen in other videos that I'm
actually angry at myself for being such
a sucker anyway let's look head over
there after this and that's your lot and
thanks for checking out the breakdown
thanks a bunch mate and definitely check
out our video on episode 4 which will be
linked on the screen right now as is
some Easter eggs in it and if you head
over there I think I'm gonna fall in
love with you now the way thanks for
sticking to the video I'll be put I'll
see you over there you take care
yourself peace